who needs it more than you  who needs this win more than you meaning  i have four kids  i have all these employees  it's not about me  it's about them  and so often especially for women i  think  that if you can tie it to something  greater than yourself you know everyone  talks about the why and simon sinek  what's your why and that's great but  it's like it's not for me it's not  what's my why it's what's my who  who needs this more than i need this  and other people are counting on me to  be strong and often i think when you  don't have the courage in yourself  you can find the courage for other  people like you've ever heard the  stories where like a parent will like  lift a car off their child who's been  pinned underneath it yeah it's you will  find a [ __ ] way when it's for someone  else